a busy bank in Manhattan transactions averaging
$40,000 a day passed through the hands of its
tellers only hitch is it's all play money
the bank is a training center for employees
of the National City Bank of New York and the
customers who maintain such a steady flow of
deposits withdrawals loan payments and the
like are either students or instructors the
idea is that real customers shouldn't be made the
guinea pigs for the training of new employees or
old employees who are moving up to new jobs
presumably they get all the mistakes out of
their system during a one to five week workout
here there's instruction in typing filing and
use of the adding machine as well as in company
organization and policy the trainees also are
given an introduction to elementary economics
learning how vital a bank's foreign and domestic
services are to our complex capitalistic system
which would grind to a halt where they're not
a smooth flow of money through the arteries
of Commerce somewhat more complicated than
an adding machine is the proof machine that
separates checks according to the banks they
are drawn on the names of the drawers or any
other breakdown required bookkeeping another
important facet of banking millions of dollars
that don't exist are totaled here each year but
this practice will help them do a better job
when they're handling your dollars and mine